hey guys i'm ryan right and I am Jerry
welcome to our show called reasons to
see where normally we would give you
reasons to Z and normally we would also
give you reasons not to see whatever
movie we happen to be reviewing but
today we're not gonna review a movie nah
today we're gonna talk about some news a
rumor that has arisen some speculation
perhaps yes some stories that may not be
true or maybe Drew and we are of course
talking about Bryan Cranston that's Lex
Luthor online so i guess we're gonna
hang out bryan cranston you know the
actor from Malcolm in the Middle is back
he is being rumored to be playing lex
luthor now sources have denied this
rumor but whom we never really know for
sure these days you know people think
they're always being rumored to yes this
is happening to know this is not
happening the idea Bryan Cranston's Lex
Luthor he hasn't a little concerned I
don't think he would do a bad job I love
Breaking Bad I know Jerry hasn't seen
breaking bad nope I have not seen
anything bad because I don't have like
I've heard what people say and if what
people say is true I cannot at this
point in my life afford to like lock
myself in a bunker for two straight
weeks watching yellow the episode it
will happen I remember going fine I'll
watch the first episode yeah and I'll
take it a little bit at a time I saw
like the first five episodes like this
in the matter of a couple hours i
managed to watch five episodes of two
hours don't know how I did it but it was
phantom Chuck Norris Genrich but no
Bryan Cranston you know he's he's
[ __ ] amazing you know he was a
Malcolm in the Middle that's what
everyone knew and has and it suddenly
did Breaking Bad and people were like
will I really buy him in this role and
look what's happening he's always wins
awards left to right for this role I
think in milk playing lex luthor might
typecast
a little bit as some as all of this fall
guy yeah some bad bald guy and I think
it'd be good sure but I think there's
other roles out there in the DC Universe
that he'd be better you know for example
Commissioner Gordon you played
Commissioner Gordon and Batman year one
the animated movie just the voice-over
work was like you know what Bryan
Cranston should be commissioned
rewarding I think they'd be great
together um Ben Affleck and Bryan
Cranston working together high school
Batman Commissioner but they boarded
work together an hour ago so they would
already have that chemistry and I think
that chemistry the chemistry probably
still show up he was Lex Luthor I just
think I prefer to see his Commissioner
Gordon like I said I haven't seen
breaking bad but I have you know I've
seen a lot of episodes of Malcolm the
middle I've seen you know his sort of
small roles he pops up in like you said
Argo and even Little Miss Sunshine State
like that I mean on the one hand I guess
I understand but I feel like the
speculation that he's playing lex
luthor's more like hey everyone loves
breaking bad Bryan Cranston's in the
public eye and he plays a bold guy he
must be Lex Luthor you know it's like if
we didn't have breaking bad i don't
think anyone will be saying that
necessarily but i can see how we could
play it because you know he can
definitely do very intense very dramatic
stuff and he can also do wacky so i can
also imagine he can meet somewhere in
the middle for something like Lex Luthor
yeah I'm sure he'd be do something he'd
do something that's unique and
impressive like I've been watching the
Superman animated series the one from
the 90s again I love the version of lex
luthor in that uh first off it's black
and secondly i don't like going it out
but I guess it's important secondly he's
a lot different than the lex luthor that
we've seen in the richard donner movies
and then Kevin Spacey doing his version
of Lex Luthor and the Richard daughter
movies there's Lex Luthor and the movies
that we've seen he's a little bit more
over-the-top kind of goofy evil guy and
in the show he's more serious much more
reserved and he's more of a badass
actually in my opinion and I think
you've got a combination of the two I
don't like what you were saying I think
that'd be really cool to watch honestly
I don't feel like I can comment too much
on about it cuz i'm not i'm not a
superman expert by any stretch of the
imagination you know it would be cool to
see bryan cranston there like I
certainly wouldn't be upset about it I
would be excited just because it's him
rather than like oh it's a dream come
true you know and I think
would fit well into this man of steel
universe they kind of have set up that's
true his is the type of acting that he
has I think it'd be great I just really
want him to be Commissioner Gordon I
know this I know this is about a me Lex
Luthor but something tells me that we
would be more satisfied if he was like a
Commissioner Gordon yeah it's like I
would almost rather it's like you it's
exactly like you said I would almost
rather see them if Bryan Cranston did
like a DC Universe or a Marvel movie or
something like that that would be super
awesome I would just rather see them get
more creative with the casting not just
go oh you're intense and you play a bold
guy right now Lex Luthor yeah exactly no
firm listen to a few other podcasts I've
heard it said that his wife really is
not down with the bald look I hope they
still have sex maybe that's part of how
he's able to be so intense on break yeah
and it's like just built up testosterone
yeah exactly it's like i have had sex so
long who would be another to be a good
lexulous aaron paul Superman Saul I'm
gonna kick your [ __ ] ass [ __ ] this
is grad yeah I don't even need to watch
it Ernie and watching Matt is the show
right this is the show here's this Jesse
mr. white he go back so I Breaking Bad
freshman readiness they should just make
Heisenberg be the next bed Superman
villa obviously the ITV and lex luthor
in this next one maybe there's that's
the way how it's like tight it maybe
Bruce Wayne and lex luthor are like
doing some type of business deals
together which brings Bruce Wayne to
Metropolis that's just for my
imaginations going I hear that Bruce
Wayne supposed to be older and a little
bit tired like he's been Batman for a
while now so III don't know how that the
stories will connect I feel like if they
did have lex luthor in it as a main
central character then it might be a
little bit barded or a little
distracting because you already got
Batman and you know so to put you know
Lex Luthor and it might be a little too
much already but who knows maybe maybe
it'll be like The Dark Knight were like
they put a whole ensemble together
multiple storylines and it just become
something beautiful at the end who knows
yeah I hadn't thought about that because
this movie is being billed right now as
Batman vs Superman it always does seem
like it would be a little bit bloated
unless they make Lex Luthor a smaller
care
sure that they're setting up for a third
film there's so many different routes
you can go with the idea of having Lex
Luthor there maybe Batman doesn't
realize alexis was a bad guy yet and
then like he's sort of helping him out
to take down Superman first or something
like that who knows maybe the people of
Metropolis were like dude this [ __ ]
alien guy just wrecked all of our seeing
Batman I know we've been having cops
after you all this time but could you
take care of this guy yeah that's the
funny thing about Man of Steel is like
everyone's like Superman's a hero but
I'm like what if shipping I was in here
this [ __ ] would I have no more
metropolis yes if Clark Kent would just
leave his past behind and he didn't
activate that beam no one would have
come to earth and [ __ ] up all the
metropolis Plitt it off for a second
there it's like I i do get at least my
understanding of that story it's like he
doesn't become the hero like the idea of
Superman that every human life is
important at all I so until the very end
of that film it's like I almost feel
like all that destruction Walker to it
is is kind of going towards that it's
like you get that collateral damage so
that he starts to realize mm-hmm but um
I could be wrong I think it'd be better
if they say Lex Luthor birth or film
because they hint to him in the in the
first man of steel you know maybe
they'll tease him in the second one but
I think to make him up a main villain
would be more interesting to watching a
third one you know what I what I want to
have it is I want them to build Lex
Luthor up like give him just small like
one or two scenes every movie
increasingly over time until like we're
about to see Lex Luthor in the fourth
movie but then a bunch of [ __ ] goes down
and the third movie sucks and then they
reboot the franchise exactly like what
happened with dylan baker and the
lizards this is stupid all right guys
ain't you listening to us talking about
bryan cranston possibly playing lex
luthor i'm sure it was very interesting
speculation for you guys but to go ahead
and scroll that comment box below and
tell us what do you think of bryan
cranston's Lex Luthor about who should
he play in the DC Comics universe yeah
and once you're done with that come on
over here and check out more episodes of
reasons to see and I feel like us like
us on Facebook and if you want to keep
you know following us follow us on
Twitter and lastly but certainly not
least Lee if you want to get updated
every time a new review or videos
out subscribe lee dr lee subscribe lee
blake lively yeah Blake lot like lively
was in the green lantern and she was
horrible I heard for all intents and
purposes that movie was I was a pretty
course of it be hard poor Ryan Reynolds
man [ __ ] good you can't do a comic
book movie i no [ __ ] origins
wolverine he you know it's like Deadpool
he was a scene stealer for the few
minutes yet he was the best part of that
me until they [ __ ] up that play yeah
Italy oh and then and then he does Green
Lantern's I thought they just RIPD is
like oh god dude you just you have the
worst luck man you're so beautiful and
you're like ruining your your image
which is what I want to track down cuz
he did some kind of at least vaguely
superhero related indie film and I want
to see if that's the one okay it is
actually good it's like the kind of
thing that you would only see if you
were like perusing a video show cuz Ryan
Reynolds is he's a good actor you have
you seem very like damn he like he's a
good actor but you know is always being
put it like these like sarcastic guy
types of uncomfortable character roles
or something and like turbo and you
should we should get the Deadpool movie
he should do it he's the perfect
Deadpool he should get that role ain't
no green Lancer and just blow it to the
side RIPD just [ __ ] forget about it
but know that the Deadpool movie should
[ __ ] happen we should do a video
about that yeah well I think it can't
happen it's like they wait is that I
think it'll happen over x like they wait
a few more years until people are
finally like dammit yeah wheres jet
goals
you